[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Hello.
Let's talk about one of the
most important roles of an API
program and agile--
the API product owner.
In agile, the private
owner is a central role
within the team and the program.
From defining the product
to guiding the API
team during a review
of finished work,
everything should be in the
view of the API product owner.
A great Venn diagram,
courtesy of Henrik Nyberg,
positions the product
owner role in the middle
of 3 responsibilities--
build the right thing, build the
thing right, and build it fast.
The scrum definition
of product owner
translates very well
in the API context.
The API product owner
is a key leadership role
when it comes to how API
products should be produced,
and how it is being consumed
upstream in the digital value
chain.
The product owner needs to
have a connected and empathic
relationship with developers,
experience designers,
and businesses leads
that use the API
products to deliver on the
experiences for the customer.
The API product owner
also has to keep a handle
on how the API team is
producing API products,
and how they're connecting
into the back end
systems of the enterprise.
The API product owner
is often very busy,
and the role can be quite
challenging in the context
switching that is required.
For example, in the
morning, the product owner
may be speaking with
digital businesses leads
to plan new experiences
that require additional APIs
in the next release.
Later that morning,
the product owner
may be working with the scrum
master and API architect
to manage the backlog and
prioritize which stories are
to be worked on in
the upcoming sprints.
In the afternoon,
the product owner
may be reviewing the results
of a recent spring and the APIs
with developers and testers.
In the last session
of the day, the
is meeting with APIs
architects and IT leadership
about potential changes that
need to be made downstream
to systems, because the targets
of the back end have changed.
What a day.
One of the key mindset
traits of product ownership
is to evangelize APIs
as truly products.
The way the product owner
drives the communication,
the packaging, the
documentation, and delivery
of each API, will
heavily influence how
APIs are consumed and produced.
This might manifest in the form
of API roadshows, hackathons,
or building a really easy to
use and self-service developer
portal.
To summarize, the
role more concretely,
the API product owner,
or PO, as often called,
is responsible
for the following.
Defining and delivering
value but making decisions
for the team on
what's more valuable,
defining the product
backlog, prioritizing
the sprint backlog,
defining requirements
as well as the definition
of ready and done,
and because of the
cross-functional demands,
a background in product
management and web
based technology
is a key skill set.
The API product owner
has to be very involved
in the day to day
sprint process.
However, depending on the
size of the organization
and the number of APIs in the
maturity of the API ecosystem,
this might not always be
feasible or practical.
It's really important
for the product owner
to recognize when demands
from people and teams
become too great for the hours
a product owner has available.
This self-awareness is critical
since the product owner
can often become a
bottleneck in the process.
In addition, since the
API product owner also
needs to network across
the digital value
chain for upstream and
downstream stakeholders,
the scope can simply
be too broad to go deep
with the development team.
In these cases, it is essential
that the product owner
figures out how and where
to delegate authority.
One such example is
in sprint refinement.
And refinement sessions
elaborate and use cases,
writing BDD use cases, and
collaborating real time
with the API architect,
developers, testers,
and scrum masters really
requires a pretty heavy focus
and time.
If there are multiple API
teams or demands on building up
the API program buy in with
business and IT leadership,
this job can be very intensive.
The API product ownership
bring on a business sense
that can act as the proxy
to the product owner.
It's important that the product
owner trains and transfers
ownership and decision making
authority to the business
analyst.
The business analyst
must have the authority
to make design and
requirement decisions.
If there are certain thresholds
that decisions cannot be made,
those lines also need
to be made clear.
Looking more strategically,
managing the backlog,
and the overall product roadmap
is also a critical activity
for the product owner.
However, when it comes
to backlog management,
the API product owner may not
want to give up full authority
to the business analyst.
Certain priorities require
organizational perspective
to determine what should
be in an API release.
These decisions may have
many strategic implications
for the overall
digital transformation,
and the overall API product
roadmap in orchestration
with upstream and
downstream projects.
However, when it comes to
the sequence in which an API
or user story should be
built within a sprint
or sprint by sprint, a business
analyst in collaboration
with the scrum master
and API architect,
can make the decisions
within the team.
At the end of the
sprint, the features
develop should be up
for group demonstration.
This is called a sprint
review, or sprint demo.
This demo could be to the
team, to the end users like app
developers, or with
other interested business
stakeholders and
executive sponsors.
There are several motivations
to demo or do a review.
They don't have to be all
crammed into one session,
and multiple demos
might make sense.
Scrum provides
frame-working guidelines
but it's up to each team,
with the API product owner,
to discuss and determine what is
the right audience and outcome.
The product owner should make
the final decision on this one
as it relates heavily to
how the organization will
perceive the API program.
Here are some common
reasons for a sprint review.
These demos can be run
by executing on a Postman
or Gherkin file, or
create a simple web
app called to show how
the API can be used
to illustrate a visual example.
The one thing we caution against
is to use the demo as a sign
off stage gate.
Demos are often too short
to allow any stakeholder, ,
a product owner or tester,
to do a final acceptance.
Furthermore, the time
spent to orchestrate a demo
and QA at the same time
can be very inefficient use
of the team's collective time.
All testing acceptance
should happen
before the sprint review.
If there isn't enough time,
don't rush the sprint review,
and do it after
the sprint is over.
Focus on the big picture.
Use the demo to
garner excitement,
celebrate accomplishments,
and gather business feedback.
Thank you.
I hope this section helped
you get a deeper look
at the role of a product owner.
It's a complex role, and
each product owner we meet
is different.
And what you learn can be
adapted and modified based
on your style, context, .
And organization.
In addition, the role can be
split between multiple people
owning different parts.
There's not just one way if
you want more information,
please check out the community
for ebooks, articles,
and other related topics.
Thank you again for watching.